and you smell what the rocks got cooking
thank you
you got to do it right
what the rock is cooking he's cooking
wax this is incredible gabriel he's the
general manager of madame tussauds great
to have you on the show thank you very
much pleasure to be here this is i mean
so life like how long can i touch it
first off absolutely is it really the
rock
it is
i'm nervous to touch the wax
how long does it take to make this uh
roughly about nine months through the
process yeah there's about a 250 photos
or measurements are taken we do teeth
impressions we go through a full
measurements they go through a
of a series of photos then the sculptors
start with creating the
the figure in clay
rotating through all the way to molding
it to wax inserting hair when they have
hair
doing color checks and all that until we
produce an amazing uh lifelike work of
art like this now he's holding the glass
for a reason what's the reason uh the
reason is uh dwayne johnson has his own
terrarium on tequila so we're in
partnership with him with an exclusive
term on a bar that's at the las vegas
location um so when if you want to come
by and stop in you can come
sample some of the rocks tequila if
you're tall enough to raise a glass with
him you're more than welcome to you can
toast the rock yes you chose the rock
absolutely you know someone's watching
at the gym right now the volume is down
they're like the rock is on las vegas
now
you have some other additions to the
museum what do you guys think we just
recently had tiffany haddish she rolled
out with us last year we've also uh
launched our new exclusive marvel 4d
film um that's in partnership with
madame tucson no wait look at this
tiffany haddish one until she moved i
couldn't tell which is the real one
absolutely it's a lot of fun okay uh so
yeah we have tiffany haddish and now
there's weddings as well yes we also do
wax weddings so if you're interested in
a walk-up wax wedding you're more
welcome to come to us we have a vip one
where we have a selection of figures you
can actually have in your wedding in
your ceremony and you'll get married by
an elvis and then you started to touch
on but you have the marvel edition as
well marvel for we do we have a marvel
4d experience which was a partnership
between madame tussauds and marvel
studios and it's an exclusive uh film
just for us so
we just rolled it out last summer it's
exciting we're wanting to get it out to
our local uh local community let them
know that we've got this new movie you
need to come back out and check us
we have something new coming all the
time you guys are non-stop back to this
guy the rock everything so life like the
teeth the eyes everything the clothes is
this the rock's actual wardrobe he's he
selected this wardrobe uh lots of times
a lot of the wardrobes are actually
donated from the talent themselves and
we put that on that [ __ ] is what's
showcasing on the figure so it's 100
we want to represent that talent for who
they are now you have have other
locations across the country are they
seeing the same rock are there different
rocks we've actually had four rocks roll
out with this collection so uh our new
york hollywood and uh orlando locations
celebrating him as an action hero all
the way to an entrepreneur how does this
so you brought him here from the museum
how did he get here is he sitting in the
passenger seat of your car and you're
driving down las vegas
people see the class we drove him up
here in a convertible um that way
everybody can get a chance to see him
that is you assemble them or
yes there are there are parts that we
have to kind of assemble and put
together because it'd be kind of hard to
transport somebody around that doesn't
move um but yes there there are joints
and things that are created for the
figure to make them stable um
but yeah and then last one too having a
wax museum here in las vegas we have to
worry about the heat
now the wax museum's air conditioning
okay he's good rock thank you so much of
course you guys are located where uh at
the madame tussauds is located at the
venetian outside the front uh by the
bell tower and this is uh so i'm just
fascinated i'm sorry one more question
the realistic life-size biceps right
here absolutely man the rock is built
yeah all right we go from the rock to
rocky we'll send it over to you i mean
you could have said